Vivek Bald: Welcome everyone to
CMS colloquium and today we
welcome James Wynn, who is
Associate Professor of English
and rhetoric at Carnegie Mellon
University. His research and
teaching explores science,
mathematics and public policy
from a rhetorical perspective.
His first book, evolution by the
numbers examines how mathematics
was argued into the study of
variation, evolution and
heredity in the late 19th and
early 20th centuries. His most
recent monograph, citizen
science in the digital age,
explores how the internet and
internet connected devices are
reshaping the landscapes of
argument occupied by scientists,
lay persons and governments.
Currently, Well, today, I think,
right saw the publication of
arguing with numbers, co edited
a volume that that Professor
Wynn co edited, a collection of
essays co edited with Jean
Michel res, whose count--
contributors investigate the
relationship between rhetoric
and mathematics. He is also
working on a new book project on
the rhetoric of Mars
colonization, from what he'll be
drawing in today's talk. So,
welcome, James, and I will pass
things over to you.
James Wynn: Thank you so much
for the introduction. I want to
I want to acknowledge and thank
Ed Schiappa, who is a faculty at
MIT. And I also want to
acknowledge that the collection
that is coming out today, Ed has
a chapter in that. So he is also
part of that, that wonderful
project. So I want to thank him
for his participation and for
inviting me here today to talk
to everybody about another
project I've been working on.
Also, I want to thank you,
Andrew, for setting everything
up for the logistics, making
this all happen, making sure my
slides were everything. Thank
you for doing that. And be back.
Thanks for the introduction, and
also for being moderator today
in our conversation. So as we've
mentioned, what I'm going to
talk about today is actually
some a new project that I've
been working on, in particular,
the first chapter of this book,
about Mars colonization. And so
what I want to share with you
today is a little bit about my
research project, my methods and
concepts. And also, then a
little bit about my findings. so
far. Now there are lots of
things that I'm interested in,
and I've I've worked on in the
book. So you don't need to sort
of, if you have questions about
other things, I'm happy to
answer them. But you know, I'll
focus today on just one part of
the project that I've been
working on. So I'm going to try,
I'm going to share my slides
here. And then I think we can go
from there. Are these slides
visible? Can everybody see them?
Unknown: Okay, great. Thanks.
All right, excellent. So just
gonna make sure I can get the
full screen.
James Wynn: So the title of my
talk today is promotional
narrative science fiction, and
the case for colonization. So
there are a few things I'd like
to talk about today. First of
all, why Mars colonization? Why
is this particular topic exigent
right now? Why is it worth
thinking about are talking about
also some of the concepts and
methods that I'm using to do the
analysis that I'm going to share
with you today. And, of course,
my findings, the the, the, the
sort of themes or issues that
are developed out of the
analysis that I've done. And
finally discussion. This is
going to be on my part very
brief, because I want to have a
larger discussion with
everything, everyone about the
topics I'm covering in my talk.
I'm thinking that this will
probably take about 40 minutes
to talk through my slides and to
show my evidence and discussion.
And hopefully we'll have a
really nice discussion after
that. So I wanted to just talk a
little bit about the public
exigence for this work. In other
words, why am I interested in
it? Why do I think it's
something that we should be
paying attention to right now.
So first of all, you know, just
two months ago, perseverance
landed on Mars. And there's been
a lot of hoopla and discussion
about that particular moment of,
of getting involved with Mars
and taking the next steps
towards sending people there
into in 2010. So essentially, in
the last five years, there's
been a lot of political movement
towards Mars colonization. Or
actually, I should say that in
the last decade, there's been a
lot of movement towards actually
devoting government resources
towards sending humans to Mars,
and making Mars sort of a
priority project for NASA. So in
a speech in 2010, at Kennedy
Space Center, Obama said, for
example, that By the mid 2030s,
we will be sending humans into
orbit around Mars and return
them safely. And then landing on
Mars will follow. President
Trump actually signed the NASA
transition Authorization Act,
which was developed under Obama
and then it was signed is one of
the first things that Trump did
when he came into office. And
within that particular document,
that that act, there is an
explicit language, that the
whole one of NASA's main goals
is to achieve the human
exploration of Mars and beyond
and just sort of prioritize this
and everything it does. So in
other words, if they're going to
build technology, it should with
it should be built with
forethought about going to Mars,
and how this is going to impact
that project. So in other words,
a lot of the planning for NASA
is now everything sort of is
related to Mars and is about
going towards going to Mars.
Also, of course, we can't forget
the interest in the private
sector in Mars, particularly, of
course, Elon Musk, and Jeff
Bezos, who have started their
own rocket companies and begun
to privatized space travel,
which has some important
implications, I think for this.
of, of these two, of course,
Ilan Musk is is very, very
interested in Mars causation,
and is hoping to see this in his
lifetime. If you go to Musk's
web page of SpaceX, there's a
particular section on Mars. And
in this section, he has this
quote, you want to wake up in
the morning and think that the
future is going to be great. And
that's what being a spacefaring
civilization is all about. I
can't think of anything more
exciting than being out there
and being amongst the stars. So
Elon Musk is very sanguine about
Mars. And that's sort of one of
his his main goals and main
priorities in the development of
his technology and his company.
Before I sort of get into the
data and the methods that I want
to use, I want to just step back
for a second and talk a little
bit about the disciplinary
perspective. I'm coming from
Professor shop, and I share
rhetoric as our disciplinary
lenses that we look at things
through. Essentially, when I go
to cocktail parties, and people
ask me, Well, what is it you do?
And I say, Well, I'm a professor
of rhetoric. And then they asked
me Well, what rhetoricians do. I
like to explain that rhetoric is
sort of the the study of
argument in all of its splendor.
And what by what I mean by that
is that rhetoricians are really
interested, unlike some other
fields that study argumentation,
and really the broad range of
persuasive means, including
emotions, including arguments
from the character of people of
the speaker, and of course,
looking at these things in
various contexts and across
different kinds of media. So,
for my, for this project, I
thought, I became very
interested in colonization sort
of generally, but specifically,
because I study rhetoric and
science and public policy, from
the perspective of thinking
about colonization, in the
context of Mars colonization.
So from a disciplinary
perspective, I want to talk a
little bit about the
contribution I think that my
project is making in the field
of rhetoric, most studies of
colonization, in rhetoric and in
other fields that are that are
closely associated with it.
Think about colonization as a
completed Act, or thinking about
the impacts of colonization
after they happen. What I'm
really interested in though, is
thinking about colonization, in
these very early moments, where,
and I call these moments
proto-colonial moments because
in these moments, the colonial
enterprise is very fragile and
uncertain. So typically, when
people talk about colonialism,
they look at already established
colonial projects, ones that
have succeeded. But I'm
interested in those projects and
very early stages when people
aren't sure that they're going
to succeed. And they also need
to really rely on argumentation
to get to persuade people to
really think about engaging in
these projects. So some
questions I'm really interested
in are one, you know, what are
the rhetorical challenges for
the colonizer? How do you get
people to buy into colonial
projects at a very early stage?
And also that how do you
previous colonial acts,
influence present colonial acts?
And finally, you know, what do
we learn by contrasting colonial
proto-colonial moments, if we
and so for my project in
particular, I want to look at
the colonization of North
America has, so these colonial
moments and then juxtapose those
with this protocol emiel moment
we're having now, thinking about
colonizing Mars in order to, in
order to talk about these things
that I think it's important to
have sort of a set definition or
a definition that I'm going to
be operationalizing or using, in
my research of what colonialism
is. So, in particular, what I'm
talking about his physical
colonialism. And what I mean by
that are the movement of people
from what are called source
communities, or metropolitan
communities into, which are
where they come from, into these
target bases, or target
communities, which are foreign
places, and also movements of
people where they're moving into
these spaces, and they they are
intending to permanently reside
in those spaces. So there's a
lot of there was a lot of
rhetorical back and forth and
sort of arguing about
colonialism as versus
imperialism. So a lot of the
discussions revolve around the
permanency of a vs versus
imperialism, which tends to be
less permanent, and is sort of a
shuffling of bureaucratic and
military folks into a space and
then shuffling them out. Again.
Another important feature of
colonialism, which
differentiates it from other
kinds of movements of people, is
that there is a notion where
that the people that are going
to these foreign spaces,
maintain political identity and
rely on the original state for
their identity, their
protection, the resources, they
need to sort of maintain their
colonial presence in this target
communities. So these are some
very basic definitional
qualities that I'm using when
I'm when I'm talking about what
a colony is, and what
colonialism is. One of the
things that's also important in
this project, and this isn't
something that I've found in my
research on defining colonialism
are talking about what it means
is this this idea of stages of
colonialism. So by reading a lot
of colonial tracks, it emerged
for me that there are different
stages of colonialism. The first
stage is what I call the
exploration stage, which is
essentially you send out
people or in the case of Mars
instruments that are there to
sort of understand that the
resources and the conditions of
the space that is, and to decide
where it has potential for
colonization, then you have the
planting stage, which is where
you put small outposts there. If
you think back to the early
colonial period in North
America, these are typically
forts with military folks that
were there to establish a
foothold. But they weren't sort
of full blown colonies. And
next, of course, you have the
settlement phase, which is where
these forts begin to expand, and
we get different sorts of people
that begin to live there. So
children, women, people from
different walks of life, like,
you know, blacksmiths, and and,
and barrel makers, and so forth.
Right. So it's not just sort of
a military operation, but it's a
diversified, more heterogeneous
population. And finally, the
very last stage of colonialism
is of course, when it
disappears. So it either
disappears to emancipation. So
in the United States, obviously,
after the after the war for
independence, the United States
became its own countries that
was emancipated from its
original colonial source, or
it's Incorporated. So you can
think about Ireland and
Scotland, for example, which
became part of, of Britain in
the United Kingdom. And so
therefore, there's a sort of
like two ways they can go, you
can either emancipate or you can
become Incorporated, and you
lose your status as a colony.
For this particular project, I
looked at two sets of texts. So
as a rhetorician, we study
typically artifacts, and
typically written artifacts. One
set of texts I looked at are
what are called promotional
literature. And I'll say a
little bit about what that means
and what that is. So I looked at
it as at 10 different texts,
which are examples of
promotional literature from the
16th and 17th century, and
particularly during the English
proto-colonial period, the
settlement of North America from
about 1495 to 1650. I also then
looked at modern science fiction
texts from the 20th and 21st
century and I looked at seven of
these, I mean, I've read lots
more. But there are only seven
that seemed to be particularly
impactful talking about
colonialism, and very detailed
in specific ways. In my
analysis, what I did is a close
reading of all these sources,
and close reading for thinking
about particular kinds of
questions. So one of the
questions I was very interested
in is, how do supporters of
colonialism persuade people to
like leave their homes and go
into these foreign spaces, which
are typically very hostile? And
also, are there sort of common
lines of argument that emerge
from their efforts to persuade
people to do this?
And so through historical
comparison by looking at early
modern texts, and, and modern
literature about colonization, I
was interested to see whether
there are similarities and
differences in the lines of
arguments that we find, and what
might account for these
similarities and differences. So
I'm going to talk a little bit
about specifically the last
question in the discussion part
of my presentation. So let's,
let's talk, let's start with the
early modern, protocol, oneo,
period. So typically, you know,
when people think about
colonization, they typically
think of colonization as
something that people really
wanted to do, either because
there's some instinctual nature
within humans that wants to go
out and explore places, or
because they thought it was like
some great, I don't know, escape
from their socio economic
conditions or whatever. But in
fact, it was really hard to
persuade people in to go to, to
go to colonize or to be part of
this sort of colonial project.
And we see this time and time
again, when you look at these
very early protocol, Amiel
tracks. So for example, John
White's Planter's Plea, which is
written in 1630, he is sort of
emblematic of the kinds of
things that you read, or that or
that these folks that are
writing these kinds of tracks,
right. So he writes in this
seminar content removed from
their dwellings and leave their
beloved country and friends, but
no man can see that we shall
find over many of that humor, we
English are known to well to the
world to love the smoke of our
own chimneys so well, that hopes
of great advantages are not
likely to draw it, many of us
from home. So many of the folks
that write these tracks, say,
it's really hard to get people
to leave. So that when I was
really interested in is the
arguments that they then made to
try to get people to, to buy
into the colonial project and be
participants in it. The kind of
literature that emerged, so
this, this actually emerges as a
genre of literature during this
period called what's called
promotional literature. And
typically, what happened during
this period is that some folks
would go over and they wouldn't,
you know, be part of one of
these fortress colonies that
were meant to sort of stake
things out and maybe make a
military foothold to make a
claim. And then they would come
back and they would say very
nasty things about being in the
colony and how, what how not
really wonderful it was. So a
lot of promotional literature
was sort of aimed at addressing
these brutes as they were
called, where people were just
sort of talking badly about the
colonial experience.
to So as a definition of this
genre, one of one historian
writes, The principal purposes
of promotional literature was to
combat the flood of slander and
malicious gossip about the
colonies, of which almost every
important writer complains. So
we have this promotional
literature, then that's meant
sort of as a rhetorical tool to
get people to think positively
about the comments. So one of
the things I was interested in
as well, okay, you know, what
kind of rhetoric do we find in
these documents in these in this
literature? And what I've, what
I found is that, typically, in
the early modern period, we have
what's called reassurance
rhetoric. There's a there's an
argument theory, theoretician
named Haim Perlman, who talks
about dissociative argument.
dissociative argument is
essentially argument where you
say, Well, this is what they're
saying. But what really is
happening is this. So it's a
dissociation of the imagined and
the real. So a lot of argument
in this vein is about trying to
correct sort of incorrect or
inappropriate descriptions of
the risk in the colonial face.
So there were lots of different
kinds of risks that these
writers talk about in
promotional literature. One of
them, of course, is indigenous
people. So here's an example of
a colonist who went to Virginia,
his name is Ralph lane, and he
came back and he wrote a very,
very scathing negative
description of the experience
that he had. So he writes about
the indigenous people that
wanted no store of mischievious
practices among them, indigenous
people of Roanoke, and the dead
of night they would have to set
my house and put fire in the
reeds that myself would have
come running out in a My sudden
amazed in my night shirt without
arms, meaning weapons upon an
incident, where have they would
have knocked out my brains. So
lane is describing his fear that
they were going that the the
Native Americans of the Roanoke
were going to essentially
slaughter all the colonists, and
that he would be a main victim
and that they were gonna sort of
set fire to his house and then
and then beat his brains out
when he ran out. Of course,
then, the promoters of this
colony needed to have some way
of responding to these sort of
negative impressions that they
were giving about the colony. So
another piece was written soon
after Harriet's I mean, soon
after the one we just read by
Thomas Harriet, which is known
as the brief and true report,
written in 1587. And this
report, Harriet tries to
rehabilitate people's beliefs
about Native Americans
suggesting that, you know, the
slanderous accounts are
incorrect. And really, there's a
very different way that we
should think about the Native
Americans. So he writes, the
rest of the day speak a word or
two of the natural inhabitants,
their natures and manners, as
that you may know how that they
in respect to troubling are
inhabiting and planting are not
to be feared, but that they
shall have cause to both fear
and love us that show and have
it with them. So he was really
trying to change everybody's
mind about these stories that
they were hearing about the
dangers of the Native Americans.
I'm not going to offer all the
evidence here, but what I can
tell you is that he makes a
series of arguments, one, based
on the fact that their
militaries are not very big, and
also that the weapons that they
have are much greater than the
English, and therefore, they're
not really much of a threat
militarily speaking, he also he
also makes a sort of
technological arguments, arguing
that the Native Americans were
so amazed by their technologies,
that they in some ways, thought
that they were, they were to be
respected and worship, because
God was so superior, and, and
that they would sort of fall in
line, just out of sheer, I don't
know, a belief that the
technology was superior, so that
they would just, they would just
sort of go along with whatever
the English have believed in.
There were other hazards and
risks. Of course, outside of
native peoples, there was a lot
of discussion in these in these
tracks about hazardous finance.
In the planners p, for example,
white talks a lot about snakes,
people were really afraid of
these snakes, they were bigger
than the ones in England. So he
had to say, say a few words
about the fact that no one
really ever sees them. And the
more people that go, the less
snakes they'll be. So the idea
here is to sort of dismiss out
of hand, the dangers of these
snakes their existence, and the
fact that they're going to
really have a problem with the
colonists. The other thing or
mosquitoes. So England didn't
really have mosquitoes, but of
course, North America was
plagued by them, especially in
the places that these colonies
were were set down.
So one of the things they had to
say is, look, the mosquitoes
aren't that bad, right? You can
wear long sleeves, you can go
indoors you can set fires. And
you know, frankly, if you live
there after a while, you don't
even notice them. So these are
some strategies that they they
had to sort of reassure
potential colonists that these
problems weren't really that
serious problems. Now another
risk that people in the early
modern period took very
seriously was the effect of the
food and climate and drink on
the bodies of the colonists. So
this is a very big deal at this
period. And now of course, as
well. So I'm William Bradford,
when he talks about the history
of the Plymouth Plantation. He
talks in great detail about the
arguments that the group of
Calvinists that that join him in
Plymouth had over the kinds of
problems that they were going to
face, and why they should or
shouldn't colonize, or decide to
build to have a colony in North
America. One of these debates
is, is based squarely around the
conditions and the effects of
the conditions on the bodies of
the members of this
congregation. So for they're in
North America, they should be
liable to famine and nakedness.
And the want in a manner of all
things. The change of air diet
and drinking of the water should
infect their bodies, with source
sickness and grievious diseases.
So this is one of the arguments
made against setting up a colony
in North America. Sort of
counter that we have. We have
tracts like john Breyer, tons of
brief and true relation. So --
essentially was traveling around
Martha's Vineyard, and he comes
back and he and he says a few
words about the food and the
drink and how it affected the
folks that were in his
particular expedition. We found
our health and strength all the
while we remain there so renewed
and increased, as
notwithstanding our diet and
lodging was none of the best yet
None of our company felt the
least grudging or inclination to
any disease or sickness. But
we're much fatter and better
health than we went out of
England. So there are a lot of
instances in these tracks where
they will talk about how the
food and the drink and
everything else actually made
the colonists healthier, and
didn't have the negative impacts
on the health that was bruited
by some of these other accounts
of, of the New World. So I'm
going to switch gears now. So
I've been talking about North
America and the colonial
experience there. So there was
some some similarities and
differences, obviously, between
North America and Mars. One of
the differences of course, is
there, to our knowledge, there
are no indigenous habitants of
Mars, we have not found life
there yet. So and and the other
thing is that no humans have
ever been there. So we can't
have the same kinds of accounts.
And and brutes have the
experience of being on Mars
because no one's ever done it.
Also, though, there is a
similarity because there are
some climactic hazards on Mars
that we don't share in our own
in our own Earth. Now, of
course, the climactic hazards
are very different than the one
the climatic hazards are very
different than the ones that you
experienced in North America.
First of all, the average
temperature is much colder on
Mars, than it is on Earth. This
is not something there are
temperature problems that
colonists had to deal with, but
not to this extreme oxygen, so
we never had to worry about
oxygen, when when setting up
colonies in North America or
other places on earth. And of
course, there is problems of
radiation, there's a lot more
radiation on that that's given
on a daily basis on Mars than
there is on Earth. So there are
definitely risks, obviously,
environmental risks to talk
about when we talk about Mars.
So, because there are no, there
is not the same kind of writing
about colonization, for Mars
that there was for North
America, we have to turn to a
new source. And so one of the
sources that we have is science
fiction. So science fiction is
great because even though
there's not a there hasn't been
a human experience on Mars,
science fiction writers imagine
what it would be like to set up
a colony on Mars and imagine
what would be like to be the
humans that are colonizing, and
what their experience would be
like.
What's also very interesting is
that science fiction writers
like like Isaac Asimov's and
Arthur C. Clarke and Ray Ray
Bradbury, were very supportive
of the notion of astral
colonialism. Even Ray Bradbury,
who who does write very
critically about colonialism,
for example, in the Martian
Chronicles, has other writings
where he is sort of very
sanguine about this idea of
Astro colonialism. So for
example, for the 1964 World's
Fair, he wrote a particular
script for this journey through
America, in which in the final
part of the script, he writes,
build pyramids of men and fire
toward land falls on the moon,
and bright new independence
days, looking back from sprays
to see our birthplace, Earth.
The old wilderness dwindles as
the human race reaches for
eternity, survival and
immortality in the next billion
years. Man God made manifest
goes in search of himself, the
great out portable nations,
which crushed the buffalo grass,
and reached the end of one
frontier now binds great defines
greater challenges in the star
wilderness above. So we see in
this the very language of
colonialism, the very language
of sort of the westward
expansion of the buffalo grass
in various comments. So it
suggests that he too, is sort of
enamored by the notion of the
colonial the Astro colonialism
of other planets. So what we
find that's a little bit
different in science fiction
writing then in early colonial
tracks, is that the rhetoric
here instead of being
reassurance rhetoric is what I
would call inspirational
rhetoric. And there are sort of
two sorts one is what I would
call heroic inspirational
rhetoric, and the other is
utopian, inspirational rhetoric.
heroic inspirational rhetoric is
really interesting, because what
it does is instead of trying to
reassure the the readers and and
the audience, that life on, on
in the colonial space isn't so
bad, they actually leverage the
challenges and the struggle for
existence within the colonial
space to make to valorize. To
make people heroes, and by doing
that also valorizing, the
process of colonialization and
the people that are going to
become colonialists. So we see
this, very obviously and Andy
Weir's The Martian, which many
of you probably have seen as a
film or you've read in the novel
form. In this novel in the film,
of course, we have the
protagonist Mark Watney who is a
scientist. He's a botanist,
engineer. And he uses his maker
skills and his rational thinking
ability to of course, send off
one disaster for another. And by
doing that sort of becomes a
hero by his ability to sort of
conquer the challenges of Mars
as a space. We also see the same
thing happening in Isaac
Asimov's The Martian way, which
is written in 1952. And in
Asimov's novel, there's also
sort of a hero scientist who's
an engineer. And the idea is
that, that Mars is being cut off
from water, and they have to
solve this problem, sort of
through their own ingenuity.
And, and I won't spoil the plot
of this. But what I can say is
that, what's different a little
bit about the Watney example,
and this heroic example, is that
the hero in the case of the
Martian way, draws their drawing
of their very ability to make
and do certain kinds of things
from their, from their existence
as colonist. In other words,
only Martians only someone who
lives on Mars, and deals with
the conditions can do the kinds
of techno can do the kinds of
technological things that makes
survival possible. So I'm off
azimoff writes, for example, we
can we can do it and earth men
can't. They've got a real world,
they've got open sky and food,
getting into a ship will
challenge them, right. We've
been living on a ship our entire
lives, breathing package, their
drinking package, water, we eat
the same food and rations, we
eat aboard a ship, we get into a
ship the same thing we've known
all our lives. So the colonial
conditions themselves, condition
that settlers to actually be
able to survive in ways that
folks that are not Martian can't
do so they can sort of solve
problems in ways that Earth
people can solve problems.
So now I'm going to switch a
little bit and talk about
inspirational rhetoric. And I
call this this argument that of
inspirational rhetoric as an
argument for larger arguments
through adversity. And what we
see here is what's called a
means ends argument. So in this
kind of argument, the the the
person that the colonist is
submitting themselves or the
potential columnist, is
submitting themselves to
extraordinary trials, which are
the means. And the ends are the
extraordinary benefits that you
reap through these trials. So
the idea is that going to Mars
is hard, but through this
hardship, we get these unique
benefits. And there is a there's
a rich history of this kind of
argument in our own colonial
experience and our own colonial
tracts. So Frederick tracts and
Turner on in his very famous
piece on the frontier, right? It
is to the frontier. The American
intellect owes its striking
characteristics, that coarseness
of strength combined with
acuteness, acquisitive,
inquisitiveness and practical
that practical, inventive turn
of the mind, quick to find
expedience, and masterful grabs,
grasp of material things are
traits are called out elsewhere
because of the existence of the
frontier. So the notion is that
the frontier, in some ways, is
responsible for the kind of
traits that made America America
that made it great that made it
unique. And so we, but it's only
through the trials of the
frontier, that you get those
kind of qualities. And we see
this very same argument being
made in science fiction texts. A
perfect example of this is
Arthur C. Clarke, the red sands
of Mars. And in this book, we
have the protagonist, Martin
Gibson as a journalist. And he's
sort of writing an expo, say on
Mars, he's going to church
Journey to Mars and talk about
what colonial life is like and
so forth. And he's really
skeptical, first about, about
the colonial project, right? He
says, you know, look, from the
point of view of Earth, you
know, Mars is a long way, it
costs a lot of money, it doesn't
offer anything, at the question
that we're all asking is, what
do we get out of it? Right? So
the whole point of this novel,
then is to answer this question,
what do we get out of it? And
after spending time in the
colony, Gibson has this sort of
a pivotal experience. And then
he becomes a strong advocate. In
fact, he becomes the PR person
from Mars. And what he finds is
that he experiences when he gets
in with the folks on Mars right.
He begins to understand that
what they gain from being on
Mars in their colonial
experience, right, is this
keen-eyed competence and
readiness to take well
calculated risks, which enabled
them not merely to survive on
this heartbreakingly hostile
world world, but to lay the
foundations the first
extraterrestrial culture So this
notion that, you know, the
utopia or a return to utopia
begins to develop through
existing within the harsh
conditions of Mars. Another
example of utopian rhetoric is
in Kim Stanley Robinson's novel
read Mars, which is part of a
trilogy. So what's interesting
is that in in Robinson's novel,
there are 100 colonists that are
the original colonists and Mars.
And the whole point of this
novel is to talk about how they
struggle to realize their
utopian vision for a particular
colony. And it's really the
struggle itself, and sort of
maintaining a pure space for
Mars, which is, which is the
struggle that if they succeed,
will have this sort of utopian
benefits. So one of the main
characters writes, all of our
says, all of our governments are
flawed. It's why history is such
a bloody mess. We are now on our
own and I, for one, have no
intention of repeating mistakes.
We are the first Martian
colonists, we are the
scientists, it is our job to
think things new, and make them
new. So the idea is that Mars is
really a tabula rasa, in which
we can build this ideal society
on and the struggle is not so
much the struggle of existence
on Mars, but the struggle to
keep this a free space in which
to create this ideal colony or
this ideal utopia that the
Martians want.
So now very briefly, I'm just
going to talk about the the sort
of the the contrast we see
between the rhetoric of early
modern colonialism, the rhetoric
of science fiction, and Martian
colonialism. So early modern
promotional rhetoric is devoted
to reassuring potential
colonists and supporters by
dismissing and diminishing the
risks of colonial life, right?
Oh, don't worry about the
serpent's Don't worry about
mosquitoes, or the indigenous
peoples there, everything's
going to be fine. inspirational
rhetoric, however, of the modern
science fiction leverages the
risks of colonization, to
valorize, the colonists and to
make a case for the good
consequences that will arise
from the colonial act, right,
you will become a hero, you will
realize utopian visions that you
have on Earth. So why, why these
differences? What my account for
it. So in thinking about these
different cases, one thing that
occurred to me is that in our
modern context, right, we have a
real faith in sort of the techno
scientific capacity to address
risks in a way that early modern
folks did not. So they had to,
in fact, offer reassurances Why?
Well, because they couldn't
really say that they could solve
the problems. But now, we have
this sort of belief in
technology and belief in the
technological progress, such
that we can almost valorize
these these moments of, of
colonialism as a way of showing
our chops of a way of showing
how we can solve the problems
and make ourselves heroes by
doing so. The other thing that's
interesting is that in early
modern colonialism, in the in
the British context, there's not
really a lot of ideal models
that can serve as this notion of
colony as utopia. I mean, the
Scottish colonization and the
Irish colonization were kind of
a big, bloody mess. For the most
part, they didn't really have
very much ideal. There wasn't a
lot of idealism associated with
it. And there were a lot of
writings by historians that
suggest that they can't really
find this kind of utopians
statements very early in these
protocol, annual periods. But
they do find them later. And we
see, of course, historically,
that these developed and smart
science fiction writers have
these as resources for making
their arguments. Okay, that's
all that I have. So, Vivek, I
will turn it back over you for
moderation purposes. So thank
you so much for listening.
Vivek Bald: Thank you. Um, well,
first open it up to questions
from our, our students. Yeah.
Natalia.
Natalia Guerrero: Hey thanks for
the talk. Um, I was wondering
what made you choose the early
American exploration rather than
I guess, like, what I think a
lot of people compare, which is
like the westward ho, sort of,
like frontier period.
James Wynn: Thank you, Natalia.
So that's a great question. So
one thing I want to say is that,
you know, the reason First of
all, kind of, I chose the
British colonialism because I
speak English. And frankly, you
know, I don't have the chops to
read, you know, Spanish texts or
texts in other languages. But
the reason why I chose North
American colonialism and not
westward expansion ism, is
because at that stage, so
there's an argument about
whether that's really
colonialism In the first place,
because America is technically a
nation and those lands are part
of the nation, although there's
a there's a debate over whether
or not and I tend to come down
on the side that yes, that is a
colonial moment as well. The
difference is that I'm looking
at proto colonial moments,
right. So in the proto-colonial
moment, there's a, there's a lot
of uncertainty about the
capacity to even establish a
foothold, or whether you want to
establish these colonies, or
didn't get people to go there. I
mean, there is some about of
course, in the westward
expansion. But I think there's
there's a stronger analogy with
Mars and the the sort of North
American settlement or this the
Yes, essentially, because, you
know, these people are really
going out into these unknown
spaces. And they're, you know,
they're, they're sort of base as
far away. And it's much more, I
think, more like Mars causation.
I hope that answered your
question. Thank you, Kelly.
Kelly Wagman: Thank you. Yeah,
thank you for the talk. I guess
I was just wondering, your talk
was very much framed from the
perspective of the colonizer. So
like, when you frame talking
about indigenous peoples, you
label them as like, risks or
harms, or like you just said,
you know, these people going out
into the unknown, where you
don't know what's out there. But
people do know, I mean, there
are people living there that you
know, what's out there. And
there's always like an other
side to that story. So I guess I
wonder how, like, why not? Why
not talk about some of the harms
that have happened in the
process? And I'm sure in the
Mars case, maybe it's not that
there are people there, but that
there are people harmed in this
process of thinking about a
single framework for utopia that
doesn't include everyone, and
kind of how even in your talk
continuing to label these people
as like harms or risks
perpetuates that violence? Kind
of?
James Wynn: Thank you, Kelly,
for that question. So what I
want to say to everyone is this
is part of a larger project. So
I'm just starting it. And my
first chapter happened to be on
this. But I will have a later
chapter that is about sort of
anti colonial arguments. Right.
So there will be a whole chapter
that I'm going to dedicate to
those questions specifically.
But the other thing that I would
say, Kelly, is that what's what
I find interesting is that
people in the humanities have
done a lot of work on the
colonized. But they've done very
little work on the colonizers.
So to me, as it as a rhetorician
that's interested in argument
from whatever from whoever's
perspective, it's interesting to
me that no one really has
written much about the colonial
arguments, the arguments of the
colonizers and why you would
want to colonize and how do you
get people to go there? So these
are, I think, spaces that are
that's under explored, which is
why I decided to explore them in
the first place. The other thing
I would say about indigenous
people on my project is, is
about thinking about how they're
imagining these these groups and
how they're talking about it,
right? So because I'm writing
some analyzing the argument from
their perspective, that's how
they're talking about it. So I'm
not trying to perpetuate
violence, I'm just trying to
open up a discussion about this
is how they were seeing this is
how they were thought of by this
group, right? And then, of
course, this can be critiqued in
1000 ways. But it's, I think
it's valuable in the first place
to know what kind of language
What kind of place that these
indigenous peoples had in their
arguments, how they thought
about them, how they argued
about that, right? Does that
make sense? So it's not that I
it's not that my intention is to
ignore the opposite position.
But that I'm taking I'm looking
at this from one particular lens
in this chapter. But later
chapters, you know, then we can
swing the lens and look at it
from a different perspective.
Vivek Bald: Um, yeah. Oh, go
ahead. Sorry, Kelly.
Kelly Wagman: I'm just gonna
say, Yeah, I I, that makes a lot
of sense. And I think you're
totally right, that like,
looking at it from that
perspective is helpful. I just
think maybe, when talking about
it, it's good to kind of
acknowledge that because I think
it can still be traumatic for
people to like, see those images
and hear that rhetoric? And so
maybe just acknowledging that is
worthwhile. Oh, yeah.
James Wynn: I mean, this is
certainly traumatic. Especially
because the more you read these
you more, you see the trauma
that happens, right? Because in
these tracks, they talk about
what they did, and what happened
and they're very traumatic.
Yeah. But I think it's important
to expose that trauma and expose
those perspectives right? As
part of what I called what
rhetoricians Guess what, logoi
which is seeing different
different sides of a particular
issue, or perspective. Um,
Vivek Bald: so I want to just
follow up on those two questions
as well, you know, as because I
know that there are some of us
here who are descended from
people who were colonized. And
for whom that that trauma is
very real and continual and
transgenerational. And I guess,
from, from the standpoint that
you're talking about, you know,
focusing on the rhetoric that
the rhetoric that was used to
encourage colonization from the
side of the colonizers I guess I
would urge you to, to, to think
about the, the underlying,
there's an underlying rhetorical
move, right. That is that the
United States is Terra Novus,
right, that that the United
States is not occupied, right,
or North America or, you know,
those lands between the Pacific
and the Atlantic, because I'm
not going to call them that yet.
So for, for this territory to be
considered Terra Novus, in other
words unoccupied territory,
there's a really deep rhetorical
move that's being made, that's
essentially, you know, the
rhetoric and, and the technology
of race, right, which renders
the indigenous inhabitants as
part of the landscape rather
than as human beings occupying
the land for generations. And
so, you know, there's that I
think that's where the
difference between talking about
North America and talking about
Mars is so apparent, because if
if you make that comparison
without acknowledging that, in
the same way that that Mars is
being considered as colonize a
bowl, right, because it's empty.
That's essentially the argument
that was made about North
America. And that that argument
was was one that entailed
violence, you know, and enabled
it. Right. So I guess that's,
that's what I would urge you to
think about, and also to think
about the colonial moment, not
as the early colonial moment.
Right. Where the colonial
moment, and as you were
mentioning, when the colonizers
break off from the home country,
but to think about the fact that
settler colonialism was a
continual process, and so even
if the east coast of of this
region was settled by colonists
who had broken off from Britain,
they were still in a pre
colonial or proto colonial
relationship to the rest of the
country. Right.
James Wynn: Yeah, I mean, it's
interesting, because I think
that that the notion of Terra
nullius is a little bit fraught.
On the one hand, there is sort
of there are sort of property
arguments about you know, land
that's available. But I think
that what these tracks show is
that they are painfully aware
that these lands are people, and
that that's a risk, and that
there are real people there,
they are rare, they are like
them they are and that they can
fight and that they are a risk.
So I don't, I wouldn't say that,
that they they're going into
this thinking like, oh, nobody's
there. Like, I think they're
very painfully aware that it's
part of their, the fact that
they have to write things like,
Oh, it's fine, you know, there
are people there, but they're
not going to, you know, try to
harm us if we live there. So, I
mean, I think that, that I'm not
sure that that's necessarily
true of the rhetoric of that, of
that of that situation. But but
it is interesting, because
they're there. And of course,
there's so much going on in this
period. Like, you know, the fact
that the the Spanish and the
Portuguese have essentially had
the world divided between them,
but with the blessing of the
Catholic Church, so technically,
this isn't even a space where
the British are allowed to go.
But after the you know, great
battle of the Spanish Armada,
and the the English winning that
battle and they feel a little
bit more, okay with, you know,
setting up settlements in
places. I mean, it's very, it's
a very complicated story. But I
don't want to diminish, I want
to dimension anyway, the
violence that were that were
done to the native peoples. And
and it continued to be done
right. So this notion that you
mentioned, what's it's called
in, in the literature, Neo
colonialism, right? This notion
that colonialism keeps going and
going, like you can't escape it.
Even after the fact, it still is
perpetuated within the system
with movies, and TV and all
kinds of media. So I'm not I'm
not negating any of that. But I
will say that, you know, I am
taking a particular lens and
perspective to look at this,
through the perspective of the
colonizers and how they're
trying to get people to go to
that space. I think it is
important to think about the
difference between Mars and
North America, especially with
the notion of indigenous persons
or indigenous life there.
Because so far as we know,
there, we have not found life on
Mars yet. And so the the some of
the issues that are very present
in discussion of colonialism on
Earth, maybe either absent or
different, and thinking about
the colonialism of Mars, and the
the presence of sentient people
who would be colonized or
destroyed or, you know, what,
whatever, is a different
question on Mars. So, yeah. So
thank you for that feedback. In
other words, thank you.
Vivek Bald: Um, there's some
questions, actually, that are in
the q&a. All right, from Jason
Lynch, what do you see as the
relationship between colonialism
and capitalism? relatedly? Have
you read or watched the expanse?
What are your thoughts on its
politics of colonialism,
exploitation and labor? And then
there's a addition to that? Do
you see any differences between
imagining of Mars colonization
versus other interplanetary and
Interstellar notions of
colonization?
James Wynn: Thank you. Those are
great. Mr. You've
Vivek Bald: seen the QA bar as
well.
James Wynn: I am. Thank you. So
yes, I see that that's at the
top by Jason. Thank you, Jason,
for your question. Yes. It's,
it's interesting, because
colonisation and capitalism are,
are very much intertwined, but
in ways that we don't always
expect. So what I found
interesting is that many of the
early efforts of the English to
set up colonies were actually
business ventures. And the thing
is that in the very early, so
the very early colonial efforts,
especially in Newfoundland,
which is where the English first
went around 1495, which is very
early, right, couple years after
Columbus. And initially, the
folks that went there like
Kabat, and others, when they
went in, they couldn't get any,
they had to, like, essentially,
sell people a story. Like, we're
going to find the Northwest
Passage, I mean, the Northwest
Passage. So I want to I don't I
know, this has probably been a
long time since, you know, in
high school history or whatever,
that you've talked about that
Northwest Passage. But I can't
emphasize enough how important
that idea that Northwest Passage
was, because at the at this
point, trade and was was really
built around stuff coming from
the east, spices, silks, all
these kinds of things. And the
way that it came into the West
into Europe, was through the
Middle East. And because of
religious differences, there was
some tensions there about, you
know, dealing with non Christian
folks. And also there was a
problem with pork prices, right.
So by the time silk, went from
China, and ended up in a port on
the Mediterranean, that you
could actually go and get it
from, it was really, really
expensive. So for these, I
really like to call them
entrepreneurs, because Cabot in
particular, and some of the
early folks were entrepreneurs,
like they were saying, like, if
we find this passage, we are
going to be rich beyond our
wildest dreams, because we're
gonna be able to bring spices
and silks, and there'll be no
middleman, we're gonna get all
of it, we're gonna get all the
benefit. We could charge lower
prices, you know, this is going
to be great. So the idea is
that, and what's interesting
about North America is when the
Spanish went into the south,
they found a lot of golden
resources. The British and some
other folks thought that they
would find the same in the north
and they didn't. And so for a
long time, North America was
just not not really that
important, because, frankly,
there weren't they weren't
finding the Northwest Passage
and they weren't finding any
goal. So if you look at the URL,
I mean, it was very it was, it
was kind of bad business. And a
lot of a lot of the early
colonial efforts just failed.
Because they couldn't, they
couldn't show profit. They
couldn't make a buck. And in
fact, the only thing that kind
of saved North America, I mean,
looking at it from the, from the
business perspective, is
sassafrass. Because sassafrass
was in high demand in England,
it was all over North America,
it was very cheap to transport,
and you can make a buck off of
it. So it's, it's strange how
like fish and sassafrass were
things that kept people kind of
interested in going to North
America, when in fact, for the
most part, it was really kind of
seen as a bad business deal. So
I know that's a really long,
that's a really long answer your
question, but I hope it shows
like how integral sort of
capitalism is to thinking about
even the possibility of
colonization, because it was a
huge risk. It was a huge
financial risk. And without
reward, people were not willing
to do it, which again, is why in
the product, protocol, annual
period, there's a lot of
interesting rhetoric and
arguments about the economics of
it. Okay, sorry. That's a long,
that's a long answer, but I'll
go to
Vivek Bald: go to another
question. Are there any
questions on the on the screen
before I go back to the q&a?
Okay. So let me see, I took one
from q&a, and I'm gonna take one
from chat now. This is from
Ricardo Perez. rhetoric is a
fascinating exploratory
discipline. The first colonizers
to America were mainly convicts
searching for liberty from
imprisonment. That was a major
motivational factor enabling the
exploration, there was also a
myth of richness that may have
been instrumental in the genesis
of the process. So Oh, and then
oh, there is a question at the
at the bottom. And why was
avatar not considered in your
rhetoric? exposition?
James Wynn: Thank you. avatar is
great. It's a perfect example of
like multinationals coming into
a pristine environment and
destroying it. I didn't I didn't
use it, because it's not Mars.
All the all of the science
fiction I looked at was
specifically about Mars, and
Mars colonization. So all of the
novels I read, were squarely
about that, just because it was
my topic area, not because of
not interested in Avatar and
other examples like the expanse
and because there's so much out
there. So thank you for that
question. But that's, that's
really, I was trying to focus on
Mars.
Vivek Bald: From Hamidreza
Nasiri in the q&a. Thank you for
the interesting talk. Two
questions if you have time for
both. First, it's interesting
that here, here when we focus on
Mars colonization, we read,
sorry, this is jumping over my
page. But I've got it. It's
interesting that when we focus
on Mars colonization, we read
those sci fi works literally,
but at the same time, many of
those sci fi novels and films
have been making the case for
American neocolonialism in an
allegorical way. How do you deal
with this kind of dialectic
between allegory and literal in
such sci fi works?
James Wynn: No, I mean, I think
what's interesting is that these
works. And we may not be
thinking about this, but these
words really do circulate within
the American public and prime
the American public to think
about colonization in particular
ways to valorize it, and to
imagine it in particular ways.
So I think that these, that
these instruments, I mean, NASA
knows this. I mean, the Martian
was sponsored by NASA, was
vetted by NASA writers, I mean
by folks at NASA. So I mean,
they realize that this is a way
to help shape the story or the
frame of colonization of Mars.
And I don't know if you guys
watch the National Geographics.
Mars series, that's a great
series. All of these series are
really designed specifically to
make particular kinds of
arguments about what it's going
to be like, why we're doing
this, it's very important to is
sort of like a prelude to
actually doing it right. You
have to prepare the audience to,
to see this in a particular way
before then they're willing to
like open the checkbook of the
national government and spend
money on these things, and spend
their lives going there. If they
do.
Vivek Bald: Okay, I'm going to
go to Kenneth Alba, and then
I'll come back to hamidreza. To
your second question. I wonder
if you could speak to the way
that hard science fiction like
Red Mars comes bundled with
epistemological claims that end
up supporting ideological
claims. I really like really
like the proto colonial texts
you brought up. But the
comparison that always jumps to
mind for me is the Robinson
Robinson aide, Robinson Crusoe.
When were the focus on
accounting and details and so
forth, has certain truth claims
grounded. Could you speak to
speak a bit to how genre
specificity and epistemology
interact in these kinds of Neo
colonialist texts?
James Wynn: Oh, that's a very
rich question. So there's a lot
there to talk about. It's
interesting Robinson Crusoe.
There are a number of films and
there's one novel that's an
amazing it's what it's called.
It's called Robinson Crusoe on
Mars. It's a great novel. By I
think his name is Rex Morgan, is
an Australian writer, or British
writer, and Australian writer
that writes, goes to Britain and
writes about this in Britain.
But yeah, the Robinson eight
does appear in in different
instances, in discussions about
Mars and Mars colonization,
particularly the notion of like
the marooned, like if you think
about Andy Weir's, the Martian,
like this notion of the marooned
scientist or the marooned
explore on Mars. So you do have
that is sort of a trope that
goes through some of the
literature. But I, this notion
of hard science fiction, I think
is very important. Because in my
estimation, the more real the
science fiction is, the more
real that it seems that it's
true. So one of the things that
the Martian that I find really
kind of compelling as an
example, is in the movie, it
seems like this is real, like
people are already on Mars, like
they're really doing this, they
can really survive. So the
realism of it, I think, supports
the supports the premise that we
could do this, or we have done
this, or we can do this. So I
think that the genre matters,
like if it's all sort of, you
know, really super fictional
and, and, and not quite so true
to life. I think it's harder to
make the case that this is true,
or this can happen, or we should
do this. So I think like, we're
his novel in this and Robinson,
who you read that you believe
that people are there, you
believe that you could do this,
and that this is how it's gonna,
it's gonna unfold. So I think
the, the the hard science
fiction is extremely important
genre in thinking about
arguments from our civilization.
Unknown: Okay,
Vivek Bald: great. I'm going to
let me see Oh, come back to
Hamidreza. The second question.
Also, I'm curious whether you're
considering making comparisons
between the rhetoric used for
the case of Israel and the
discourse, arguing that life
actually originated on Mars, and
then transferred to Earth, the
argument of original home for
colonialism.
James Wynn: Interesting. So
actually, um, I had been
thinking about Israel, but not
in that sense, like the notion
of like, life starting on Mars,
and then coming to earth. I
really haven't thought about
that. So that's a great angle,
and thank you for that. But I
have been thinking about
colonization in different
spaces. And so this notion of
setting up cabooses as sort of
being also as a way of thinking
about colonization, is that
colonization? If so, why, or why
not? Or, you know, what, what is
this sort of language or the
arguments for these kinds of
settlements? I think I've looked
into it a little bit, not a lot.
But I was kind of intrigued by
this notion of thinking about
whether there might be some
analogs there, that would be
useful to help me think about
colonial arguments and colonial
moments.
Unknown: Okay.
Vivek Bald: Ali has a question.
Do you want to? Do you want me
to take the question from the
chat or would you like to?
Alison Lanier: I didn't drop it
in the chat. Sorry.
Unknown: Okay. I can,
Alison Lanier: I can just say
it. Um, I was also really
interested in your reading of
Kim Stanley Robinson's read Mars
series, I really wanted to ask
you about your reading of it as
utopian and heroic, which is
really interesting to me,
especially with the overtones of
like the Martian exceptionalism,
and the people on Mars are going
to achieve X, Y and Z. And
especially just with like the,
the, how, how the Faultline show
in that, I was wondering how the
how that exceptionalism plays
into the narrative of
colonization if that makes
sense, I can
James Wynn: Yeah. So like this
notion that like, we are an
exceptional people, therefore,
you know, we have the right to
colonize here or it is our
destiny to colonize here sort of
thing,
Alison Lanier: or the sense that
people who are on Mars or the I
believe the quote you used was,
we won't make Earth's mistakes
or something along those lines,
that kind of thinking.
James Wynn: Yeah, I mean, so
it's really interesting, because
in the beginning of Robinson's
book, you have 100 colonists,
right. And they train in
Antarctica. And they're supposed
to give like reasons why they
want to go to Mars. And most of
this is supposed to be like, Oh,
well, I'm really interested in
this science, or we could do
this thing. But when they all
get on the spaceship, and
they're away from Earth, they're
all like, screw it. The reason
we want to go to Mars is we want
to build a new society, because
we're tired of Earth, the way
that you know, earth, society
and capitalism, and everything's
messed up. But we're going to
start sort of a really a new
utopian world on Mars. And of
course, what's interesting about
the novel is that it's a very
about half of the novel, the
first half, they're able to do
this, and they're there, you
know, they've created this place
called Underhill. And they've,
they've started to make their
utopian ideas come true in some
small ways, and they're thinking
and planning how to do it. And
then they find gold on Mars. And
the minute gold is found on
Mars, all the transnationals
show up, and all of a sudden,
it's just like Earth again,
right? And so there's this
notion of, there's this constant
tension between like, and then
they have to go under ground and
they become revolutionaries. I
don't want to roll the whole
plot of the, the novels, but but
I think there is this notion
that, you know, their ideas are
pure and correct. And, and that
all everything that Earth stands
for with capitalism and, and big
government, right, and not
allowing, like small self
government or allowing people to
form their own groups and do
have their own lives. I mean, I
think Kim Stanley Robinson is a
libertarian, so much of the
libertarian thinking kind of
comes out in his novels. So I
don't know if I've answered your
question in LA. But I think
there is this notion that, that
this is the right way to think
about how the world should be,
which is essentially an anti
capitalistic perspective, but
then things are more
egalitarian. Thank you.
Vivek Bald: Natalia had her hand
up a moment ago.
Natalia Guerrero: Yeah. Um, so
I'm, I work in exoplanets. And I
have also seen that in the space
community at MIT and Aero Astro
as well, there's been a big move
in changing the language of how
we talk about humans going to
the moon, to Mars, or like, in
the very distant future
exoplanets. And it's becoming
very unpopular to say colonize,
or we're trying to actively tell
others like maybe we shouldn't
say colonize, maybe we should
say explore or visit. And
rethinking it like as scientists
and like NASA decadal surveys
are starting to, like, include
that in thinking about the next
10 years. And so I'm really
curious about this section in
your project on anti colonial
thinking and what that's going
to look like.
James Wynn: Thank you to
totally, I hope, maybe we can
connect, because I'd be really
interested in talking to you a
little bit about the kinds of
language changes that you're
seeing and the kinds of
documents that might be able to
look at to talk about this.
Because I think that's
fascinating, that that, you
know, because if you look at
NASA stuff, it's pretty colonial
focused, at least during the
periods I've been looking at. So
it's interesting that they've
kind of cottoned on that this
might not be the best framing
for this. And they might want to
think rhetorically about
changing the way that they talk
about their their exhibition.
There. They're traveling to
exoplanets and Mars and other
spaces. I'm trying to think I
hope I'm not losing the thread
of your question. Um, could you
just repeat the last part that
you said, because I think I lost
that thread?
Natalia Guerrero: Yeah, I was
curious if you could give like a
brief outline or like teaser,
like, What? What the path is
going to be for like the anti
colonialist. Yeah,
Unknown: so your project.
James Wynn: So it is
interesting, because there are
so I mentioned Ray Bradbury
earlier on the Martian
Chronicles is actually, science
fiction that's very anti is sort
of focused towards anti
colonialism. Because what he
talks about is how one you know,
like, some of the space
travelers go to Earth, the
Martians aren't too excited
about having them they're like,
they don't think it's great, and
they end up like trying to
eliminate them. until of course,
all the Martians die of a
disease that's brought from
Earth right which is I'm Anna
logic to the smallpox outbreak
in the United States after
European settlers got here. So
we see a lot of this sort of
like, he's reminding us of all
of the the atrocities
essentially, that occurred when
when they colonize North
America, right. So these are
very much present in Bradbury's
work, which is interesting given
the sort of juxtaposition that
it has with that quote that I
showed you earlier. So there's
sort of like maybe a fraught
relationship for him about about
this moment about going to Mars.
The other thing, there is a very
interesting environmental
argument where, you know, humans
go to Mars, and they trash it.
So they're throwing junk in the
towel, and essentially doing the
same thing to this planet that
they did to Earth. Right. So
this notion that humans aren't
going to change, and they're
just going to get this new,
beautiful planet, and they're
going to destroy it. And I think
Kim Stanley Robinson also talks
he there's there's a there's a
lot of discussion about
terraforming, which is a very
central part of his novel. And
so terraforming is going to be
an interesting way of thinking
about colonialism, because it's
like Uber colonialism, you're
not only like showing up in a
place, you're just completely
transforming it so that you can
live there. Right, which, you
know, we've done that in a
number of ways on Earth. But
this is like taking it to the
next level, where you're just
totally taking this ecology of a
planet and completely changing
it. So it's your own needs.
Right? So there's that issue.
There's also issues of race,
there's issues, especially. So I
don't know if you guys know Gil
Scott Heron, but he has this
really great song called whities
on the moon, right, where he
talks about how essentially, you
know, we could be using their
money for space projects for
special projects on Earth. Why
do we do that? There's also the
same environmental arguments
about why don't we use the money
that we could be exploring Mars
to work on climate change on
Earth, right? Why? Why don't we
worry about on planet earth and
not worry about going living on
other planets. But sort of the
racial inequities also come out
in other kinds of stories about
questions of like, so they're,
they're like, I think it's
Philip K. Dick, where he talks a
lot about like, these people go
to the moon, they work as
miners, like Who are these
miners, like? Well, they end up
being people that were poor on
Earth, that they could just sort
of exploit and send to Mars,
which is a terrible environment,
to extract resources, and then
bring them back to Earth where
everybody else is rich. So
there's, there's a lot of this,
this sort of notion that
colonialism is going to be
they're going to colonize,
they're going to just, it's
going to it's going to be
extractive of resources, you're
going to have the same folks on
earth that are taking risks and
labor to take those risks on
Mars. And on other planets. You
also see this in the expanse,
right where the folks that are
working on I can't I can't
recall the name right now, the
folks that work on the outer rim
of the asteroids are all like,
sort of poor folks that are, you
know, their rights are trampled
on. And they're just sort of
exploited for their labor in
these very dangerous spaces. So
we see those. So those are like,
that's a preview of the kind of
things that I'd like to talk
about. And I'd be interested to
hear from anyone else if there
are other kinds of issues that I
think are worth talking about,
with respect, and of course,
afrofuturism. If we want to talk
about race and space, that's
something also that's important
to talk about, think about.
Vivek Bald: Thanks, I'm going to
go back to the q&a. See, where
was I, from anonymous attendee
Have you read? And do you have
thoughts on a memory called
Empire, often noted as an anti
Imperial space opera?
James Wynn: Thank you. I have
not read them. So um, thank you
so much for bringing to my
attention. I just wrote it down.
I've got a little tablet here of
writing down stuff people are
asking and saying, so a memory
called Empire. I am going to
explore that. Thank you for the
source. I've always the more I
can get, the more I can look at
the better I the happier I am,
the better I feel.
Vivek Bald: Next from yen we
have you read how Jing founds
vagabond? And if so, what are
your thoughts on whether there's
a difference in the ideas of
colonization in this Chinese
science fiction text compared to
the English texts that you use?
James Wynn: So I have not I have
not read vagabond I have heard
about it. There's also another
text whose name escapes me right
now, but I think is by a Chinese
author. And the whole premise of
the story is that essentially
Earth sends and receives signals
from an extraterrestrial life
form. And then they realize oh
my god, If someone can send and
receive these signals, it's very
likely that they're going to
like come to us, and that we're
going to be colonized. So
there's about Yes, thank you the
three body problem, thank you so
much. The name of the novel is a
three body problem, or, and so
the idea is that, you know, what
if what if we should maybe not
be sending all these messages
out to space, because we could
be the next place to get
colonized by some, by some, some
folks out there that have more
technology than we do. So that's
a very interesting sort of
alternative perspective. But of
course, you know, there are the
sci fi flicks from the 50s and
60s, where you know,
extraterrestrials come to earth,
and like, how to serve man right
as a menu and not, and not a
doctrine about how to help men.
So anyway, I think that was the
Day the Earth Stood Still, but,
but there are lots of there are
lots of examples like that where
you have films about Earth being
colonized. But I think the
Chinese writer is that that
particular series I think, is
very interesting. The three body
problem.
Vivek Bald: All right, thanks.
I've been going to the list a
lot. Are there? Are there other
graduate students or anyone else
on screen? Who wants to ask a
question?
Unknown: Okay,
Vivek Bald: I'm going to go back
to the list then. And then I
have one other question. But I,
I'll go through a couple more.
Oh, this is from carto. Again,
what factor commands the massive
commitment of national resources
to explore a hostile environment
and not the ocean?
James Wynn: Yeah, interesting.
That's a great question. Um,
factor, of course, is
international, one factor is
international prestige. So one
of the chapters I'm going to be
devoting my into my book on is
about the politics of, of, you
know, space research and, and
Mars colonization. Because think
of if you think about it,
there's a really famous speech
by Kennedy. It's called his moon
speech, which was given at Rice
University, and I think 1961, or
63. In the speech he sent, he
essentially says, and this is
the arduous argument I was
talking about my talk of
argument from difficulty, he
says, we go to the moon, not
because it's easy, but because
it's hard. And the idea is that
if because it's hard, if you can
show that you can do it, then
you're better than everyone
else. So essentially, it's a way
of, you know, having national
prestige. And it's worth putting
a lot of money into endeavors
that show your national
prestige. So if you think about
Mars, and especially Mars in the
last like, two months, China,
the United States, and the
United Arab Emirates have all
sent either probes or landers,
or all the above to Mars. And
the notion is that there is a
new, in my estimation, a new
space race on India, China, the
United States, the European
Union, everyone is competing for
these for reaching these extra
terrestrial spaces and living on
them. So I think that this is
going to be heating up in the
way that it was heating up in
the 1960s. And in the end,
Kennedy's speech, I think is
very evocative of what I see
happening now. So why would we
spend the resources because if
we don't, we're going to be
second. And we can't have
national pride of place. So I
think that that might be one
reason why we will do it.
Vivek Bald: been very good about
answering a lot of questions.
James Wynn: I love these are
great questions. I do this.
Vivek Bald: So I'm going to take
one more from the q&a. And then
then I have one, one last kind
of follow up. And this is well,
there are a couple of
recommendations. A couple of
scholarly recommendations for
following up on some of the
earlier comments, marked
earnings, racial world making
the power of popular fiction,
and john writers colonialism and
the emergence of science
fiction. And then in the other
list, there's a reference to
parable of the sower. And have
you read parable of the sower
and thought about the rhetoric
for dispersing through the
cosmos like seed on the wind?
James Wynn: That's a very common
trope. Actually, Isaac Asimov
talks a lot about this. He talks
a lot about us as the Footloose
Vikings of the future.
Interstellar Vikings, that is so
we get in our long ships and we
go out and we spread the spread
humanity throughout the
universe. And a lot of the
argument there is well you know,
you have all these blank spaces.
And what we want to do is we
want to create awareness of
these faces, and you can't have
awareness without people. So
therefore will bring people
there. It kind of goes back to
Vivek, your your notion of Terra
newless. So there is this idea
that well, if, if if nothing's
there, it's not very valuable.
But if people are there, we can
make value of it. We can make it
exist in a way that it doesn't
exist if there aren't people
there. So there's some very
interesting arguments.
Definitely this this Footloose,
Viking of the future is Arthur
C. Clarke, Asimov, all those
guys talk about this. And a lot.
Vivek Bald: Thanks. So what I
wanted to just circle back to.
And I think I was still kind of
trying to articulate this. But
it goes back to I guess the
question I asked about whether
or what kind of rhetorical moves
are being made to to represent
certain spaces around the globe
as colonizer bull by Europeans?
and other words, what is
necessary? You know, and this is
why, you know, I think that that
kind of early articulations of
race and racial difference and
the kind of emergence of racial
science that, you know, in a
sense, those are, those are the
rhetorical the repositories of
the rhetorical moves that are
being made to render to render
certain spaces inhabited by non
European people considered,
like, fair game, right. And so I
guess that that's, that's part
of what I was getting about
getting at earlier, and whether,
you know, whether you can sort
of talk about the tracks,
without talking about a kind of
underlying set of assumptions
about colonize, calling,
colonize ability, that, that
maybe don't appear in the
tracks, because they're already
sort of settled through other
kinds of rhetorics of
civilization of racial
superiority of, you know,
Christian religion in relation
to other religions. So I'm just
interested to hear a bit about
that before we close out.
James Wynn: Yeah. Thank you.
And, and this is going to send
me back deep into history, if
you don't, if you'll bear with
me for a second. Um, so yes,
there, there are very formal
arguments about this. And what
some people may be surprised to
know is that, particularly the
Spanish were very concerned. I
mean, initially, they were fine
with whatever was happening, but
then they got really concerned
about it. And they actually had
a series of debates about
whether that this was even
appropriate. And by looking at
those debates, you can see sort
of what are the bases of
argumentation and it has a has a
history that goes beyond even
even the the 1492 journey of
Columbus, essentially. So in
order for a place to be
considered colonized double or
like, you know, that you can
claim as property, right? So the
word the appropriate, whereas
dominion, so place that you can
go and claim dominion over
right? There were a couple of
things. So one is that that
place that space, cannot be
occupied by a Christian King. So
Christianity comes into it right
there has to be there. If
there's a Christian King there,
it's a no go. You can't just
claim dominion over that. The
second thing is there were lots
of debates over whether or not
the persons in that space, were
civilized. So this goes all the
way back to Aristotle. And if
you if you look at the debates
over these spaces, there are
certain criteria you have to
meet to be considered civilized,
you had to have a language, you
had to have a written language,
you had to have a social
structure. That was that was
obvious, like a hierarchical
structure with like kings and
whatever. Also, you could make a
case for civilization based on
buildings. So like if you had a
town and things are laid out and
your temples and stuff. So one
of the challenges was, you know,
some people that were against
these, these early colonial
pushes, especially by the
Spanish are like what, they have
written language, they have
towns, they have kings, like,
you know, you can't claim that
these people don't have they're
not civilized because they
actually do have all these
things. There are other parts of
the doctrine though like
cannibalism. So if you were a
cannibalistic society, you could
not be considered civilized,
right? Because that is the most
sort of uncivil thing you could
do is to eat other people. So, a
lot of this sort of false
arguments about cannibalism
amongst certain groups of
indigenous peoples are all aimed
at suggesting that they're not
civilized, right? Because they
couldn't make an argument on
these other grounds. So so there
was there, those were want.
That's one set of arguments. So
you had the sort of like, the
legal arguments about the
Christian King, the arguments
about whether the people are
civilized. And then there was a
third set of arguments that were
that were there were actually
sort of like economic arguments.
So a lot of a lot of folks that
were doing colonization, were
trying to find a middle way,
where they were saying, like,
okay, we recognize your
civilized, we recognize your,
your Dominion to some degree
over these places that you're
in. But what we see is that
there are all these uncultivated
spaces. And so what we're
suggesting is that if a space
isn't cultivated, like there's
not fields, there's not, you
know, animal husbandry, we can
occupy that space. Why? Because
you're not using it. Right? So
in this way, they're not
suggesting, though, that they
have dominion over the whole
space, they're just suggesting
that they can move into specific
niches, which are undeveloped,
and develop them, and claim
Dominion through development. So
there's also this sort of third
argument about Dominion through
development. So those are like
the three I would say, main
cases that people are making
about why it's okay to colonize.
Vivek Bald: Yeah, the last one,
is, is quite interesting in the
sense that, you know, the, it is
another place where you can see
the intersection of capitalism.
And, and, and these colonial
processes that you're talking
about, because capitalism only
sees land as productive when
it's right when it's productive
in a capitalist way.
James Wynn: Right. In fact, I
think it's from Locke and his
discussion of property that a
lot of people draw these these
arguments from.
Vivek Bald: Right. Well, we're,
we're just two minutes over
time. Thank you, again, for
fielding. Quite a quite a number
of questions. And thank you for,
for sharing your work with us.
And, and, and thank you
James Wynn: all for just a
wonderful conversation and great
questions. I'm definitely
keeping me on my toes, trying to
get me to remember all the stuff
that I've read or thought about.
So I really appreciate that. And
I'm glad to hear your questions,
because it also informs the
kinds of topics and issues that
I do want to explore as I
developed this book, as I said,
it's in its in its protocol.
It's in pro stages, right? So I
have one chapter written, but
I'm looking forward to writing
the other ones based on the
feedback and discussions I've
had here. So thank you so much.
Vivek Bald: Right. All right.
Thank you. Thank you. And thank
you to everyone who, who
attended today, and we'll see
you next week. Great.